okay so this is Goliad um I think scary
it's like really scary
bubble gum makes this thing that's like
supposed to rule after she dies and it's
kind of like just this big creature
that's supposed to kind of be like her
clone ish it has a little bit of DNA but
also has just a bunch of other candy
stuff so but she's worked really long
and hard hasn't slept it was like 83
hours or something like that and an finn
and jake say oh well we can teach her
how to roll and leave and stuff and
she's gotten don't sleep so she's like
okay whatever and this is what sleep is
important that's like the one thing you
can draw from this okay so like he takes
a nap I keep talking about it so they
try the teacher how to be a good leader
Jake screws up and yells at some kids to
get them back in line and deserve it
damn it
they were pretty Brady and she mistakes
this that's how you should always lead
and they discovered more and more her
powers which is like not only that she
can serve turn big and stretch out long
and stuff but she can also mentally
control people which i think is like the
scariest scene to me just when it's like
you know hey Finn do it and you know no
you gotta do it through like you know
being kind and nourishing and stuff like
that and she's like no I'll just make
you do it through my mind and just like
like he just leaves his brain his eyes
go dead he just like his body is like a
course that flies this thing it's just
it was really creepy
so bubblegum comes and says hey we have
to she's too far gone we have to stop
her makes a clone based on Finn's hair
and they we don't know if they win we're
assuming they you know the good guys win
because they're just at a stalemate and
I guess oh did she say probably okay
Gabe gave up his life or whatever his
himself so he could pretty much stare
her down for all eternity wow that's
kind of sad but cool hard to sleep when
people keep
sorry and eventually they just yeah
they're a state Leia they find out
that's kind of in son because it uses
his DNA and he's just like happy
birthday Stormo and it stops there um
well I said the big thing or hey stand
up for me is how creepy this is and I
really mean that I think there's this
thing is very designed kind of it just
really like I don't like looking at it
you know and I mean that in a very
complimentary way cuz it's supposed to
be creepy um and I think the Fantas have
this very innocent childlike voice who
just can snap you can snap your neck in
a second if you wanted and she's trying
to debate why she shouldn't and it's
like no I just
sounds like fun I think I should do that
there's just there's something really
creepy when you're trying to talk to a
kid that just like does not understand
and you have to really go super super
simple to explain things and they're not
getting it and they have all the power
in the world kids yeah
love those kids toilet to an episode it
remind me a bit of that yeah this was a
little creepier I guess that kids should
scare me a little bit more in twilight
zone because it's like anything he can
think it will just happen but that's the
thing it's to be with the twilight zone
it's not so much a childlike innocence
it's yeah he knows what he's got and
he's gonna use it goliad is more
childlike like oh yeah I could totally
do that if I want to well you know I'm
gonna have a little bit more fun yeah I
think it's kind of like if you watch a
movie or like okay this characters gonna
die and they die
it's our like okay whatever but if you
if there's that wiggle room like maybe
they'll get out maybe they won't it's a
little bit more sociable so I think what
they're trying to reason with her and
there's a little bit more room for
argument and she's like you know but why
would I want to do that why would I be
nice the video you just watch the VC you
like to bring back the light vinegar
no I like this I like this it's that
trying to Ruiz it cuz then there's a lot
of pressure and yourself like what I say
what would I do you know how can I get
this kid to understand and it's where
with the twilight zone kid it's like
there's just nothing you can do yeah but
they're making it look like there's
nothing you know they can do um so yeah
I just four creeps I like this one but
but I also like I like that she made
another one whatever storm or whatever I
like that they're always at stalemate
that sir seems very like I want see
Greek mythology maybe there's another
well there are like looking for their
sphinxes so you got a little bit of the
Egyptian now yeah there and since you
know Sphinx is pretty much just stone
and stays there for all eternity good
point too yeah um but you know I mean
like those stories where it's like you
know now they're always gonna be doing
this from eternity you know is there a
lesson learned is there is it just a
tragedy instead of it
I like that nd I like that they're
always gonna be looking at show there
and I'm actually like I'm sure some
people are like well I want them to wake
up I want to see more had you would like
if they just stay there like yeah and
maybe once a while you see them by the
background or something like that you
just know that's always going on it
makes a little bit more tragic but a
little bit more fascinating to well it
also kind of adds to the innocence
suspense if you will what happens part
of the building breaks whereas normal is
yeah many folks and the connection is
broken or someone tries to interrupt
them yeah you know so good maybe the
snail will come break the connection oh
my god the Lich yeah and maybe like just
all go to it would be pretty cool
yeah it'd be pretty cool where I said
I'm surprised people didn't bring up
blur Doug didn't bring up when Lily had
forced Jake to eat like everyone that
was pretty fight yeah going through the
oh god I'll tell you kids
I'll tell you my absolute favorite is
when she's trying to read mine and he is
constantly trying to put the plan out of
his mind and the creativity
and and how visual they get with it is
all really funny but the one that really
got me laughing is you know remember the
plan the plan is in her head just turns
into a dolphin just makes the dolphin
seven yeah and the water and then just
and the constant I love this our battle
of the literally of the minds I guess
you know just like there and you see if
both visually mentally just like you
know he would start to get the plan but
then like you know he come in another
way and like you know sir like bring up
the ground and you know pull her over
but then like she'll come through his
hair or something and then he'll turn
into the dancing baby that he was or
something which I'm sure you were happy
to see so uh no I thought all that stuff
is great
that's very creative or are the kids the
little asshole kids see I hate old
people and I hate kids
yeah it's everybody but me pretty much
um you know your kid is right over there
right she's not a kid anymore she's a
teen that's true so that's a hitch
kid ish but not a kid um so when the
kids are flipping out and everything in
Jake's trying to be nice and they're
like crawling to his brain
and they start crawling into is like
orifices I'm like whoa that's just a bit
you know
yeah but beyond if you saw five other
kids do it it's like youto I do it now
it is the Gator just a follower do you
have anything to say I liked it too I
would like to have everybody take note I
thought it was quite interesting I'm
wondering if it's where I was gonna sit
right at the end Finn says Bulletstorm
looks exactly like Goliad how comes
Stormo is a good guy because because he
has your DNA bouncing like you what's
that say about exactly because Goliad
has Bubblegum's DNA so you know could be
maybe I'm not such a bad person maybe I
was kind of a little bit right about her
maybe while I was gonna say maybe it
does make me kind of wonder if Floyd cuz
we don't know much about a lot of these
characters pass if maybe she was kind of
originally like that cuz she said she's
too far gone you know so maybe it's like
she's knows what it's like to be at that
point but she was kind of like saved at
some point where she didn't have to be
necessarily bad you know and they she
was very controlling and domineering or
something like that at some point but
she leveled out know who else who else's
DNA got into the mixture that's right
cinnamon oh that's all that's know maybe
there's more to cinnamon bun
more maybe it's the fact that Finn is
just innately heroic and he's always
just willing to help out and the first
thing that Stormo did yeah
it was first think of a storm what did
was just like I need to help out let me
know come because I had time to kind of
start maturing as little as it was and
the first thing that storm did was oh
yeah I've got to do that okay I'll do it
yeah what was seeing it Jake was say hey
here's our lesson and the first thing
she saw was him yelling at the kids and
like okay that makes sense and she tries
it and it works and there's you know
she's like I see no reason why this
would not work you know it's like me
wrong and there's no room for error he
did the one thing and that was it yeah
you know cuz no I was thinking the same
thing what's that say about bubblegum
but ya gotta toss in what Goliad
actually learned what else got into that
concoction cinnamon bun damn that
cinnamon bomb I bet that's too much it's
too much logic that makes sense I know
my theories like devil water but you're
right like you know if she was taught it
yep you know it was by accident but she
was taught in the area where the bird
okay
oh great bad or whatever you know
you know I like that was just like wave
program to do or whatever and like
that's what the first thing he sees he's
like you know okay let's go in boom yeah
I also love that bubble gum sorry well
my voice cracks bubble gum yes
bubble gum is trying to teach Goliad
about you know the bird or the bee and
the flower and all that stuff and I love
was filthy by the way that was filthy
I love the I love what Goliad says
because most people don't ever take it
into account
no the bee doesn't give a crap about the
flower at all the bee is getting what it
loves and then leaves it doesn't matter
- flowers dead or alive as long as the
stuff is still there what am i cap
goalie it's got a very good point there
well that's what I like it's like just
how how do you how do I teach these geez
you know just how do you teach something
it's like so it's gone in one direction
but you know you're right and most of
the world knows you're right but how do
you you know explain something just the
world kind of knows it's like it's way
you know what does the word Thommy and
it's like well everybody knows but you
have to explain it's like it's tricky
it's like it's very hard to actually
explain so it's kind of like really
working backwards and trying to do it
fast because it's like you don't do a
fast no she's gonna be like no I'm gonna
kill you both
ya know so to a blind person what the
color red is yeah you see the movie
masks they kind of did it kind of sort
of to see the movie
you want to be rocky Dennis you better
drink your milk
were you in masks